auf dem foto hier neben wir da sehen sie
mutter annika mit ihrem kleinen logan
mama und sohn lieben sich über alles das
erkennt man sofort doch dann entführt
der ex mann den kleinen logan nach der
kita ins ausland mutter annika die
eigentlich das alleinige sorgerecht für
das kind hat ist komplett verzweifelt
und die spur die führt nach thailand
genau dort haben sich jetzt unsere
reporter nachdem ex mann und dem
entführten kind auf spurensuche begeben
lilly von der osten und hannes rafik
berichten
es ist der albtraum jeder mutter das
eigene kind tausende kilometer ins
ausland entführt kein kontakt kein
lebenszeichen seit mehr als drei monaten
ist annika ball genau in diesem alptraum
gefangen am 24 september entführt
annikas ex mann den zweijährigen
gemeinsamen sohn logan ins ausland ich
habe nur
ausgelaugt ich bin emotional und
kräftemäßig unglaublich ausgelaugt
annika ist tattoo-modell und influenza
online nennt sie sich held at any für
ihre mehr als 30.000 follower film zu
ihren alltag in dülmen in
nordrhein-westfalen 2018 lernt sie
logans vater den briten dale es kennen
die beiden verlieben sich schnell folgt
der antrag und annikas schwangerschaft
mit logen
2009/10 heiraten dale und annika in
thailand doch die ehe kriselt bereits
kurze zeit später trennt sich die
influenza in von ihrer man logan bleibt
bei seiner mutter bis zum 24
september 2021
eine e mail von meinem ex-mann bekommen
eine sehr lange e mail in der er mir
mitteilt dass er sich jetzt mit logen
ein neues leben aufbauen wird gegen
hätten ja sämtliche richter und
jugendamt und polizei würden ihnen ja
alle nicht ernst nehmen und niemand
würde ihm helfen und ich habe diese
immer gelesen und mir war sofort klar
hatte ich altanlagen entführt
annika erstattet anzeige die
staatsanwaltschaft übernimmt die
ermittlungen und rekonstruiert des
fluchtweg am 24 september flieht der
brite mit logan aus dülmen nach
amsterdam dort sendet er annika noch die
e mail und steigt in ein flugzeug in das
fast zehntausend kilometer entfernte
phuket in thailand weitere ermittlungen
übernehmen die deutschen behörden jedoch
nicht auch die deutsche botschaft in
thailand kann annika nicht helfen die
junge mutter ist auf sich allein
gestellt
[Musik]
doch annika gibt nicht auf einen monat
nach loh ganz entführung engagiert sie
einen privatdetektiv der ermittler reist
nach katong denn baillys bruder betreibt
hier eine 6 bar genannt horn pub im
rotlichtmilieu pockets nach kurzer zeit
spürt der detektiv dort logans vater in
einer bar unweit vom horn pub auf
trinkend und mit freunden feiern
der privatermittler beobachtet dale es
für einige tage im rotlichtmilieu und
verfolgt den briten bis zu seinem neuen
wohnsitz er observiert die
apartmentanlage in der hoffnung auch
logen zu finden und tatsächlich der
detektiv entdeckt den zweijährigen
spielend am pool von seinem vater keine
spur annikas sohn wird von zwei
unbekannten frauen betreut
mutter und sohn endlich wieder vereint
es wirkt zum greifen nah doch obwohl
anika lorenz genauen aufenthalt kennt
ist ihr martyrium nicht vorbei annika
hat zwar das alleinige sorgerecht für
ihren sohn doch dallas begeht keine
straftat in thailand denn in dem
königreich ist kindesentzug nicht
strafbar die thailändische polizei
unternimmt nichts um logan zurück zu
seiner mutter zu bringen annika bleibt
nur der weg über die deutschen behörden
und der ist langwierig und teuer wir
haben super viele infos wir wissen
eigentlich alles was wir brauchten um so
einen zugriff zu planen uns fehlt aber
einfach das geld das fehlt als das geld
fast vier monate lebt annika jetzt in
ungewissheit nach ihrem bewegenden
öffentlichen appell bei bild live
schickt achtung fahndung einen reporter
nach thailand um dale es mit den
vorwürfen zu konfrontieren
unsere kollegen finden ihn exklusive
aufnahmen zeigen den briten vor wenigen
tagen im rotlichtmilieu in patong doch
ein gespräch mit achtung verhandlungen
verweigert dale es stattdessen lädt der
brite dieses video bei youtube hoch
indem er über 20 minuten versucht sein
vorgehen zu rechtfertigen
doch annika gibt die hoffnung nicht auf
wie eine löwenmutter kämpft sie jeden
tag um ihren logen bis er endlich wieder
zurück in ihren armen ist
und bei uns im studio begrüße ich jetzt
eine cabal die mama von logan hallo
guten abend und thomas katz elektra bei
uns ist vom verein sos kindesentführung
guten abend genannt erst mal zu ihnen
frau bei uns ein ist bei der recherche
das wirklich nahe gegangen wie geht es
ihnen wenn sie jetzt die aufnahme ihres
sohnes aus thailand sehen schlecht weil
ich nicht weiß wie es ihm geht und ich
einfach unglaublich verzweifelt bin weil
ich einfach nicht an ihn ran komme ich
komme einfach nicht an ihn ran sie haben
jetzt noch mal bestimmt auch probiert
dem mann zu schreiben gab es da
irgendeine reaktion oder einfach
fundstelle totenstille absolute also die
nummer war kurz nachdem er in thailand
war auch nicht mehr aktiv da kann man
ihnen überhaupt nicht erreichen und da
außer dieser youtube videos gibt's halt
absolut überhaupt gar keinen kontakt
also wieder telefonkontakt kein schrift
kontakt keine fotos nur dieses youtube
video in dem er auch ganz klar sagt dass
ich meinen sohn nie mehr wiedersehen
werde es gibt dieses eine foto und das
zeigt ihren sohn mit völlig fremden
frauen wie ist das als mama wenn man
sein eigenes kind mit fremden menschen
sieht das ist einerseits natürlich sehr
beunruhigend weil ich diese personen
einfach nicht kenne man vermutet dass
die thailändische frauen in dehrn ii ist
was sich aber dadurch erklären lässt da
der herr ist es ja natürlich im
rotlichtmilieu tätig und tätig ist und
das tag und nacht einerseits ist das
erschreckend dass sich jemand fremdes um
mein sohn kümmert andererseits kann man
sagen dass es vielleicht besser ist als
wenn der herr ist dass selbst tut denn
wir ja die fotos und auch die aufnahmen
zeigen wurde der mann auch von den
ermittlern beim koksen gesehen das ist
mir auch nichts neues ebenso dass er dem
alkohol wirklich sehr zuspricht und
wirklich sehr viel und häufig dringt
dass es da vielleicht
ein kleiner wermutstropfen ist dass er
von einer nanny sag ich jetzt mal
umsorgt wird anstatt vom fahrer selbst
dieser schrecklich fall ist ja kein
einzelfall mehr als 500 solcher kindes
in führungen gab es allein
2020 woran liegt das sind die deutschen
behörden da nicht gut genug vorbereitet
nicht wachsam genug ich denke dass es in
deutschland eben zu
nicht entschieden genug vorgegangen ist
die behörden sagen sobald festgestellt
wird dass das kind mit einem anderem mit
dem anderen elternteil unterwegs ist ja
da kann ja eigentlich nichts schlimmes
passieren es besteht keine
kindeswohlgefährdung aber genau das
gegenteil ist der fall ticken da kommen
dann oft wenn sie überhaupt zurückkommen
oft traumatisiert nach hause haben dann
jahrelange therapien vor sich und keiner
will quasi das sehen will einfach keiner
sehen es gibt bereits jetzt nach dem
strafgesetzbuch die möglichkeiten
international dieses als verbrechen
einzustufen weil das natürlich eine
psychische entwicklung also störung
entsprechend nach sich bringt und somit
als ein verbrechen ist aber das wollen
die behörden part in deutschland nicht
machen wir wissen nicht warum was raten
sie annika weil was raten sie in so
einem fall wo das kind nach thailand
verschleppt wurde also
sie haben schon wirklich alles richtig
gemacht ja sie haben sich nicht auf das
handeln der der behörden verlassen sie
mussten ja selbst quasi tätig werden um
zu sehen wo der kleine jetzt da ist und
jetzt auch der richtige weg an die
öffentlichkeit vielleicht kann man durch
die öffentlichkeit mehr druck auf die
behörden ausüben damit die
entscheidenden schritte dann noch
unternommen werden ich hoffe dass die
staatsanwaltschaft das noch überdenkt
und einen internationalen haftbefehl an
ausspricht vorbei wenn der kleine logan
das jetzt hier sehen würde und wenn ihr
ex-mann das jetzt hier sehen würde was
würden sie jeweils den beiden sagen was
ist ihnen wichtig zu werden was ich
meinem sohn und mein ex partner sagen
würde mein sohn ist zwei jahre
demnach würde sich wahrscheinlich fragen
warum es die mama ist gerade im
fernsehen und der herr es wird dass hier
definitiv sehen der verfolgt hier
jegliche medien in deutschland und er
wird sich kaputtlachen und ich würde ihm
sagen dass er sich warm anzieht weil ich
auf dem weg bin meinen sohn zurück zu
holen und ich da guter dinge bin dass
wir das schaffen denn das ist der grund
warum ich jetzt damit an die
öffentlichkeit gegangen dann wünschen
wir ihnen dabei alles gute das sind das
gelingt ihr sohn zurück zu bekommen gab
select auch in vielen dank dass ihr
heute bei waren dieses große und
wichtige thema über das auch vielleicht
zu wenig gesprochen wird danke ihnen
beiden und vor allem für sie viel erfolg
dankeschön dankeschön
[Musik]